hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to Blanchett 101 that's
disgusting
you don't have one of those pesky ideas
that seems unique original and
charmingly inventive don't you just hate
those what I can't we make something
that's tired and dated with no
originality whatsoever what can it be
more like blank check
for you see blank check is the height of
cinematic blandest taking a relatively
clever and new idea and sucking all the
creativity out of it so it becomes a
forgettable piece of knife leaving no
impression at all how could any film
accomplish such an incredible feat well
let's watch this pathetic piece of ass
dropping stuff find out now most films
would begin with a unique way of showing
their title trying to distinguish itself
and give it its own style
I'm not blank check they just show it my
god is that uninventive as if to say
really your ticket stub is the only
written title you need for this film
anything else would just be an
extravagance we see a criminal named
Quigley escaped from prison and get a
briefcase of money that he hid while he
was put away we then cut to our main
character named Preston good I've given
this some time and I've decided that why
I think he's really talking to his dead
that's why we're in this tight
uncomfortable shot that doesn't show his
father right why else would they
obviously frame this in such an awkward
way oh it's a goldfish you see this
trick has been used a dozen times in
other films but that just adds to the
blandness that blend check has to offer
I sure hope there's more to be
unimpressed by that is the way stick boy
oh there is to love but not just
brothers who'd like to pick out him all
the time you mean we get to
unintelligent bullies that have no human
emotion outside of just being a
stereotypical teen antagonist it must be
my birthday partner so apparently
Preston is upset because his father
treats his brother better because
they're trying to start their own
business and Preston hasn't yet even
though he's like seven they need the
space for their business young man and
this family industry gets rewarded while
you're in here playing your brothers are
hard at work surprise Preston maybe you
could teach your brothers how to use it
oh and did I mention that he's the only
one who knows how to operate a computer
yeah
the two brothers who want to start their
own business don't know how to operate a
computer more bullshit please Damien and
brow sleep but to face butt to face say
bye at to face hi
it by Ladyface turn it by babe we can't
let a computer that nobody outside this
room can hear top somatic about us
thanks
don't rub it be a man
don't rub it be a man yeah I had that
t-shirt growing up too so president is
invited to a birthday party of a kid who
doesn't like him and not sure how that
works as the kid greets Preston in a
classic manner it's presto mephesto
oh right I always trust his need to be
twenty years behind what's currently
popular personally I would prefer the
psyche Hitler oh so because it's cheap
as father given such little money he
only gets to ride the dorky rides while
all the other kids get to enjoy the
long-term rides proving that money is
the only thing to make you truly happy
you need some cash yeah we got a bunch
of change it's not fair why can't I have
anything well Preston they have jobs and
they willing to say how can I save money
if I don't have any and you saved is a
penny earned
meanwhile they quickly guy goes to visit
an old friend was an owner of a bank it
turns out his bills are marked
so he's gonna send in a guy named juice
to get new ones why can't you just get
him now because this is pleasure
101 I want that title screen so Kristin
goes to the bank to see if he can
deposit just eleven dollars when we're
introduced to
hot chicken oh my god
hi can you see okay oh yeah sure ah I
would like to open an account please
eleven dollars do you have any other
money you'd like to deposit mr. waters
I'd like to make a deposit in your skirt
I mean uh-huh yeah that's what I meant
I'm afraid we have a minimum balance
it's $200 come on our house
whenever you're ready please come back
and see me okay my name's CheY Stanley
thanks bye-bye boy I sure hope I can buy
you at the end of this movie so
president gets his bike run over by the
Quigley guy who sees a cop and forgets
to write out the amount in the check to
cover the injury so you think his folks
would be relieved aides okay right not
gonna be a practical world of blanchett
101 I thought we understood about taking
care of our valuables it was a piece of
junk
well if that's how you feel about a gift
from your parents I don't see giving you
a new one for your birthday I don't want
a new bike I want my own room I'm
warning you you're on thin ice as it is
about the bike what I want is my own
house
that's it young man until further notice
you're grounded that'll teach him to
almost get run over I almost had to
summon an emotion there so person
realizes that he has the blank check and
decides to put it to good use good
old-fashioned criminal use did v court
just gasp so he tries to deposit the
check book is called in to the head of
the bank because they don't believe we
have a little problem here what is it
mrs. Lewin sir someone thinks this is
some kind of game I see is there much of
a line out there mrs. intimates yes
we're swamped
what are you doing here please is it me
or is the actor playing the head of the
bank the same actor who's playing the
female teller could they do that make
them
juice don't things I'm not Thursday
that's right he mistakes the kid for a
juice you see all the dogs are friggin
idiots in Blanchett 101 especially in
kids films however it turns out the real
juice is downstairs asking to see the
head of the bank as well look at my name
is juice and I got some righty and I
wanted to be so kind enough to cash it
for me okay who is this guy anyway he
seems to pop up in my reviews all the
time he was the non surfing brother in
surf ninjas a horny singing lizard in
Fern Gully and now he's a con man in
this stop following me strange man with
kind of cool voice or toe lock whatever
the hell your name is
boom you're sweet for what you know boy
I'm sorry you know you ought to be in
school don't make me sing about our own
gonna eat you if I'm gonna lay somebody
so the bank guy finds out he's been had
as the kid first decides to buy a
freakin castle with the money he just
got and wait you know it the quickly
guys trying to buy it - that's a smart
escaped convict trying to draw as little
attention to himself and keep a low
profile by living in a castle hello good
afternoon I'd like to make a cash offer
on your house well I'm a total moron so
continue I have an offer on the table of
300 about we have a gesture for things
are poisonous
my name is McIntosh well congratulations
mr. McIntosh I think you mean mr.
product plug you have a house so Preston
uses all his money claiming that belongs
to a fictional guy named McIntosh but
wait a minute this movie almost has a
creative premise going truly there must
be some way we can make it more
conventional how about a comic relief
limo driver there we go and make sure
not one word of his dialogue is funny
wait for client here but I'm a client oh
right yeah and I'm Madonna if you want
to ride in this need some buckaroos
buckareenies some moolah some dinero
some money some frog skins much similar
to the money you've given me in fact
identical to the money you've given me
right now I was just kidding about pay
Madonna
uh-uh I love comedy believe that
provides no comedy or belief but wait
don't planned uninvented comedies need
to have mindless montages oh yeah the
movie stylin now oh did I mention that
the limo drivers along for the ride too
I don't think he invited him a longer
anything you just start coming with
it's okay the rich Haji this story seems
way too simple isn't there some way we
can make it needlessly complicated well
it turns out that attractive banker is
actually not a banker at all she's an
FBI agent trying to find the money that
Quigley stole before that seems totally
unneeded and implausible wait a shitty
it up movie I almost enjoyed a few
seconds there hey you know this guy uh
what what is a mcintyre ah McIntosh yeah
why does he get a kid like you to go out
and buy all his stuff for him yes he
never had a real childhood so no he's
really really rich he could have all the
fun that he couldn't have when he was a
kid sounds like a modern day Michael
Jackson to me ladies and gentlemen I am
personally glad to have made the first
Michael Jackson joke since he died I
miss the man we all do but the time has
come to laugh again
laugh at the honest laugh at the strange
behavior
but the field bad taste hold you back
you see Michael Jackson was an odd
person very very odd person but the
reason we can still land that is because
he was also something that we could
never take
geez don't be
no matter how hard laughs he will always
be jealous I've been the statute
the time has come to laugh plus log
anyway question comes across Shay the
FBI agent who doesn't question at all
that a kid is riding in a limo and
suddenly has money now so uh I'm
thinking about going into the bank
tomorrow opening my account wow you got
the $200 already just about all right
well see you tomorrow bye bye Jagger
uber King so he orders a bunch of
product placements as a ton of
adjustments are made to the castle and
his douche dad is none the wiser
yeah who is Mackintosh I want worse
thing yeah but who is he I never met him
not Morgan no I haven't met him you sure
about you really ah a couple seconds of
development and explanation aren't
really crappy montages we can cut too
here we go that's right
bring on the Neela's panic continue to
film scenes that are only made for the
trailer you know I'm starting to wonder
if you can really get this much for a
million
I know it's a lot but I don't even think
Donald Trump could have a house like
this so she starts to think there's
something suspicious about mr. McIntosh
no I think so Preston convinces her to
go on the date where he assured her then
mr. McIntosh will appear and read the
limo driver gives him some pointers oh I
smell hilarious quirkiness coming up I'm
gonna tell you about the real deal on
dating which I know okay first of all
women love a great body
they love look at this bod whoa see you
know of course you know you got a bod
now that's of a Greek god really think
about I mean women like you have a good
bod cuz they want to feel the protectant
might have to fight some guy you know
but not with those arms you want to hit
a guy with those arms cuz those pythons
that take a guy's head off that
all-you-can-eat salad bar women love
that
take some with you you know why are your
pockets with plastic bags put the food
in there cuz it doesn't say
all-you-can-eat here does it say here on
the side I don't think so I apologize
there was clearly nothing funny in there
I quite frankly don't know what that
scene was about so Preston lets his
family know that he's going out to help
McIntosh again even though he's grounded
McIntosh may have a pile of money but he
doesn't decide when my son is or isn't
grounded grounded so much for playing
for for - what do you know about planned
for for - I didn't want to say when I
told mr. McIntosh about your plan for
four - and he was very very interested
yeah I promised to my bring a copy of it
tonight you show it - let me get you a
fresh copy of the prospective of it
sweetheart
it's good to know that this movie is
teaching young kids that love can be
bought maybe I should go over and eat
know why you ruin everything
he's a date tonight and he's very
nervous about it I'd be up pretty late
this woman
lucky dog and officially more
dysfunctional than the Manson Family he
dresses up in a suit that even The Fresh
Prince of bel-air would find a bit much
as our seven-year-old hero tries to wine
and dine a 20-something year old FBI
agent mr. Macintosh is very interested
yes
he's never met anybody like it before
he's never met me before period
technically no but he's been thinking a
lot about you lately kid yeah hit him
hit puberty yet girls are just cootie
filled gross magnets at that point oh
and the world's greatest FBI agent still
doesn't catch on that there's something
weird about the fact that she's dating a
Kim right now
perhaps we could analyze this and
understand why neither their motivations
match their characters but not in
Blanchett 101 it's been over two minutes
how about some lame jokes
is he an entrepreneur no he's American
good good and since there's clearly no
interest in developing our characters
let's end with a pratfall
Oh Duane check your quest for cinematic
forgetfulness is beyond compare
so still benign to the whole dating a
kid thing president takes her to a spot
that he knows she'll enjoy
Oh
so even though he's gotten wet what is
probably a very expensive outfit she
just seems to laugh and giggle
throughout the whole thing okay I'm not
a woman but if I was I would deck the
little bastard but she may not have to
is the criminals fuck Preston and try to
NEVEC all right Blanchett 101 get ready
for wah-wah music and shrug in three two
one
he got away again
he got away again oh oh hey I guess the
banker guy was so upset you felt back to
the ground in the jump cut
I sure hope they don't get wet again hmm
so did Preston's plan to embarrass
himself and ruin her outfit work in his
favor oh it's such a good time
me too good night Preston night Shay
oh the high five of shame it's one thing
if they hug you we're trying to shake
your hand but a high five that's gotta
hurt so the crooks find that one brandy
kid and force them to tell them where
they can find precedent why don't you
just tell me what I need to know round
numbers I don't think you get the
picture Sonny maybe need a better view
you know Phil India thank God you just
cut to that picture of the same building
and stuff dangling me off it or else I
would have really been scared so Preston
says he's gonna have a birthday party
for Macintosh but it's really his
birthday so he finds out that he's
actually spent all the money and can't
pay for the party just at the same point
where the father comes in and of course
mistakes him for Macintosh you don't
have kids do you mr. Macintosh well I
tell you it's very easy to make mistakes
with him I haven't always paid enough
attention my kids may feel like I never
see my kids even when the right in front
of me
I'm afraid he's missing out on his
childhood
so am i this Beach is terrible we
appreciate you sending Preston home
early after his dad leaves he sends
everybody home and waits in the castle
by itself where of course the bad guys
arrive so some burglars are trying to
break into a place and there's just one
lone kid there to defend it what's that
movie that everybody was trying to rip
off at that point in time Oh
home alone I just so happen to have the
whole no ripoff checklist right here
let's get marking impractical trap below
my unimaginably stupid villains jig
intuitive shot to the crotch resulting a
cartoony sound effect Oh check unfunny
dialogue hoping to be turned into an
obnoxious cat face oh well the hilarious
moments ever stop ripping off other
hilarious moments so of course the bad
guys catch up with him and they're about
to make him pay this looks like a job
for a predictable conclusion bring in
the cops who just so happen to show up
at the right time FBI be termen so the
bad guys get arrested as Preston tries
to see if there's any future for him and
Shea so when can I see you again Shea
hmm why don't you give me a call and say
about ten years five seven six
okay it's a date
here so Preston goes home not to an
angry house of parents who should
rightfully punish him but to a birthday
cake to celebrate another year on this
planet so I guess the moral of the story
is bad deeds always go unpunished and
money is the root of all happiness but
really would you expect any other
message from the Disney Corporation so
now you know how to turn your creative
charming little idea into an
unimaginative depraved piece of
forgettable bland shit just watch blank
cheque as a reference and you'll do fine
and now I'd like to turn off my calm
Pleasant teaching demeanor in order to
show you what I really think about this
movie fuck you
oh I feel much better
I own this - a critic I remembered so
you don't have to